Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Welcome to Shashingo!
What's the pun?
On... Shashin?
On Nihongo.
Shashingo.
Or if it's Shashingo, wouldn't it be like photography language?
Teach us Nihongo!
Today...
Today, I would like to play a game to learn Japanese!
In this game, you take pictures of people.
And you learn Japanese.
Let's all be weebs together.
Nihongo Jouzu.
Mito-chan, Nihongo Jouzu.
That's not true.
Thank you very much.
The weather is nice, isn't it?
Wow, you're really good.
No, no, not yet.
No, no, no.
Nani?
My Nihongo is very sugoi.
I believe you.
Actually, yesterday...
Was it yesterday?
Yes.
Yesterday, Matara and I, we both bought our...
Our...
Oh, sorry.
Something fell on my desk.
Our tickets to Japan!
So before...
Oh, I can read Kanji.
Sugoi.
Kanji...
I can't read Kanji.
No, no, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Ore no Nihongo!
Yeah, we bought our tickets to Japan.
So now it feels so much more real.
But...
Oh my gosh, this music is going to put me to sleep.
Um...
Uh...
What was I going to say?
It was so funny when we were buying them.
We were buying them together.
And I bought mine.
I ended up like...
Fin...
Like I ended up putting in all of my information first.
And buying my ticket first.
And then she goes to buy hers.
And we got ours separately.
But...
Um...
We put our seats next to each other.
And...
Um...
Uh...
When she went to go buy hers, it said that it was sold out.
So I was like...
I didn't take it.
I didn't take...
Um...
But in the end, it worked out.
It was pretty...
It was too slow.
And I took her seat.
Japan is so hot.
Well...
It's hot here too.
It's hot in Mint too.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, that scared me.
I like the lo-fi of this.
I really wanted like a kind of chill game.
And uh...
Um...
Something that...
Uh...
Do you know Riiiguma?
Riiiguma!
Riiiiguma!
Ummm...
Ummmm...
What's his name?
Oh no.
Uhhh...
Uhhhh...
Ummm...
Oh!
Steve Jobs!
Who's this?
Riiiguma is...
an English meme.
It's an English meme.
Don't worry about it.
Please.
Who is Steve Jobs?
We can study...
Your Japanese is really good.
Thank you.
Today is actually my birthday so I can ask for a happy birthday from Porsche Red.
Oh my gosh, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Oh, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, David Titanium PP.
Happy birthday...
to you.
You little...
peasant.
Your Japanese is good.
Thank you.
I'm looking forward to a photo tour with Mint.
Hi Mint.
Hello.
Hi ViviCore.
Posh voice Jozu.
Everything is Jozu.
And not everything can be Jozu.
Not everything can be Jozu.
Let's do it again.
Japan has over five mil...
Oh.
Oh my god, it's so loud.
It's raining!
Welcome to Shashingo.
Here you'll use your camera to create unique photo flashcards for learning Japanese.
You're free to explore your surroundings and study at your own pace without any pressure.
Oh, in-world translations.
Besides learning new vocabulary with your camera, you'll also come across Japanese text in various places while exploring.
Interacting with the text will allow you to view the original Japanese text along with the translation.
Oh my gosh!
I can't hear you over the sounds of Japan.
Five million what?
Five million!
I'm looking forward to Shashingo.
Also, I can read the kanji.
A little bit.
I can read it.
I'll give you this joke.
Wait, I'll give this joke one more try before retiring.
How do Japanese pirates apologize?
I'm sorry.
What?
Wait.
Huh?
Oh my gosh, it's so quiet because...
Hold on.
I'm gonna get through...
Let me get through this real quick and then I'll turn the sound down.
Open your camera when you're ready.
Learn how to use it.
Okay, hold on.
Made...
Made dreaming!
I'm sorry.
Made melody.
Okay, audio.
There we go.
Oh my god, peace.
This is like going to real Japan.
This is like real...
This is like going to real...
Wow, the first thing we see is a main campaign.
Oh my gosh.
Made...
Made melody.
Oh my gosh.
Very good.
Where are we?
I wonder.
I wonder where we are.
Oh wait, how do I...
Oh, right click is...
Watashitachi no natsu no yoru.
Rainbow team.
Hey, that's not Nihongo.
That's not Nihongo.
Let's see.
What do we...
Let's take a picture of the maids.
Oh, operating the camera.
Operating the camera is easy and there are only a few buttons to remember.
To take a photo, simply frame your subject by adjusting your position, angle and zoom.
Then press the shutter button when you're ready.
Oh, I'm so excited.
Oh, there's filters.
Oh, wow.
Tsuki ga kirei desu ne.
Oh my gosh.
You'll get kicked out if you take a picture of the maids.
You're so right.
Don't take pictures of the maids, you guys.
While it's not mandatory, holding the shutter button allows you to lock up...
Lock on.
I'm lock...
You can adjust the composition even more freely.
Release the shutter button.
Okay.
Oh, releasing the shutter button will then take the picture.
Framing the subject correctly.
Oh, look at that.
You can make it look so much better.
Your subject needs to fill a good portion of the frame to be recognized by the camera.
Genji!
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
As long as the viewfinder displays...
Or Japanese word, you can freely take a photo.
Okay.
Well, this one.
Let's see.
What is maid melody?
Kasha!
Kanban.
Kanban!
Oh my gosh!
They're not maids at all!
They're a signboard!
Oh my gosh.
I recognize all of this from Irastoya.
Kanban!
Nice photo!
You just made your first photo flashcard.
As you can see, the subject of the photo was written on it in Japanese along with the translation.
Flipping it will also reveal an additional related message.
I don't know what they have to do with the kanban but...
Kanban!
We have a photo album.
We can get star stickers.
As you master words, they'll also receive star stickers.
Marking your favorite.
In-game lessons?
Wow!
Oh!
Whoa!
It's night time!
Uh-oh, I hope no creepers come out.
Let's see this one.
What do you guys think this is?
Don't say it.
This is Sakurai Station.
The moon's out?
Wait, how do I get out of camera mode?
Oh, you're right!
Zoom.
Lock on!
Moon!
What's the...
Night.
Cold weather.
Yeah.
You don't eat something and say it's cold.
You say it's cold.
Karaoke.
Wait, why is the question mark here?
Oh!
It's the whole karaoke?
Karaoke.
Sing!
Wow!
I'm happy!
Got to see my best friend.
Got offered a new job.
I have been streaming...
Oh, my birthday!
Cooper!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Cooper White!
Woooooooo!
Happy birthday!
Oh, testing your memory.
Find mode puts your memory to the test to reinforce your vocabulary knowledge.
You'll be given one of the Japanese words from your photo flashcards and tasked with photographer...
Photography-ing...
Photo...
Photographing!
Photographing it in the game world!
Hahaha...
Cool...
Word mastery...
And we can get new fi- Oh my gosh, there's gacha too.
Oh, heck yeah.
Students are 10% off.
What's this?
Advertisement.
Advertisement!
Poster.
Chigaimasu.
Oh!
Sendensuru.
To advertise.
Yuko.
Effective.
Miryokuteki.
Appealing.
Oh my gosh.
When you see...
When you see a mint channel, you're like...
Oh!
Wow, miryokutekina channel.
Oh, I should douroku right now.
Oh, I can't do these though.
Thank you!
Tsuki ga kirei desu ne.
Oh wait, Joshua, I missed yours too.
I'm so sorry.
Good day to you, mint.
I hope you are having a wonderful day.
Wonderful minty day.
Thank you!
Have you ever watched any films in the gai- gaiyou genre?
I don't know if I have.
I hope I said it right.
Hahaha...
Oh...
Uh...
Shashinto kawaii obake...
Maido...
Oh, meido.
Wait, wait.
Maido?
Mai...
Wait.
Oh, is it meido?
How was my broken nihongo sensei?
It's good.
Don't worry about it.
Let's take his picture.
Oh!
Which one do we...
Do I hear someone singing in here?
Hold on.
There's voice lines?
I think I hear a ghost in here.
Oh!
You hear it?
What are they singing?
It was a lady singing before.
She was like...
Shashin ghost.
That's why...
My...
It was my art tag.
But my general tag is...
Shinrei shashin.
Which means like spirit photography.
Hahaha...
Interesting.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Konnichiwa.
Wait, what did you say?
Do you watch anime desu ka?
Na sugoi desu.
Watashi wa I'm learning Japanese.
Through all the anime watashi watches desu.
Watashi love talking about anime.
X3.
Na so uu.
Have a konbanwa!
Have a konbanwa.
Everybody.
Wow, we stayed up all night in front of this karaoke place.
Is this...
Is this shizen?
Oh, gosh.
My kanji.
Mira yo.
tsuku...
Is it tsukui suru no wa?
This is just... I don't know... I can't read it.
It's just a mecha.
I'm going back to nature.
To watch.
Engidu.
To perform.
Kando teki.
Moving.
It was my birthday yesterday.
I had a fun, low quality, high latency discord karaoke session with my friends and watched Dune 2.
Is that the one with the...
Is that the one... Oh, she didn't tell me.
Is that the one with the popcorn?
To Chonky.
Also, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to Chonky.
Wait, do I just click it?
Oh!
The only way to save the future is to live.
Only one mecha.
Live.
Only one mech can save the future.
Future world.
Future... Oh, I didn't even see the three.
Future world three.
Shizen ni modoru.
Return to nature.
Happy Eiga.
Rainbow team.
Rescue... Oh, it does say rescue mission.
I was like, it just says rainbow team, rainbow team.
Space.
Komanda.
Kinta?
Kinda?
Oh, Kaneda- Kaneda-kun.
Oh shit, this is just going to make me look so stupid.
I'm really bad with kanji, you guys.
Kaneda-kun.
Kanjin, doushite?
Onyomi-kun yomi muzukashisukeru yomenai.
Pinku no sora no shitade.
Under a pink sky.
This is the iriguchi.
Your entrance.
Oh, I can't read the... Okay.
I can read the Eiga-kan.
Is it raku?
Something...
Raku...
Go-raku?
Entertainment cinema.
Oh, go-raku ega-kan.
Go-raku, go-raku, go-raku.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh!
Guitar star!
Boo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo.
Boo-doo-doo-doo.
She's got a smile that seems to me.
Reminds me of childhood memories.
Where everything was as fresh as the bright blue sky.
Guitar star.
Wow, I feel like this is actually so helpful because it like...
Actually kind of shows you things like...
That you would really see in like...
In a context that you would see it.
Hanabi taikai!
Wait, can you read that?
Maybe you have to zoom in.
Sora.
That's the skin.
No!
Sora.
Akarue.
Kaze.
Kumori.
Beautiful.
Wait, so if I take a picture of...
Oh, whoa, this is big.
Is it just ega-kan?
Ega-kan.
Ega-kan, everybody.
Miru.
I'm going for a date?
Did someone say the door detectors?
D-d-d-date?
Haku-ryoku.
Impact.
Date.
Good thing you'll never need to know that.
I wonder how big this map is.
I know what it says.
It lasts 48 hours.
Natural scent that lasts 48 hours.
I can't read it though.
That's the thing about kanji that I do like sometimes.
This is like the kanji for tsuzukeru.
And the kanji for... Sorry, my brain.
But I can't read them together.
But I know what they are separately.
So it already means... I can already make an educated guess.
I've already dated all your oshiminto.
Who?
Who have you dated?
Tell me right now.
Tell me the date.
Tell me the time.
Tell me everything that you did.
Tell me their natural scent.
Tell me what they wore.
Tell me how they did their hair.
Tell me the color of their eyes.
Tell me what they said.
The first thing that they said when they saw you.
Tell me everything.
That's what I thought.
Have it on her desk by Monday.
Look at her with her natural kaori.
I have no money.
It's all the filters though.
Okay, I should be taking more photos.
That's the point of the game, right?
Oh, what's this?
Wait.
It lit up.
Oh, wait.
It's Koraku again.
Wait, but what else lit up then?
I saw it.
We saw it, right?
Oh.
Oh, it was just reminding me.
It was like, dummy, you already took a picture of this one.
Idiot.
God.
What about this?
What do you think this is called, everybody?
Gamer laptop.
Gamer.
Note-o-pacocon.
Happy streaming on my birthday.
Why is it everybody's birthday today?
This game is a surprisingly good way to learn Kana for beginners.
Oh, nice.
Crazy person, happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear crazy person.
Happy birthday.
How much you want to bet one of the synonyms or like the related words is Takai?
What a scowl to use.
Let's get it.
To turn on.
Download.
To download.
Gosh, you have to pay.
You have to pay so much more just to get the RGB.
What do you think?
Oh, my favorite show.
Ah, no.
I missed it.
Oh, my gosh.
She's so loud.
To watch.
To turn on.
To turn off.
Is that mine?
Why is there just a phone in this box?
It's not my birthday.
It's not your birthday as well?
Well, here's some money for non-birthday-haver Minty Ghost.
This is a cute game.
Thank you for the non-birthday money.
What about the phone?
Sumaho.
Sumaho!
Kakeru.
Juuden suru.
That's an important one, isn't it?
Denwa bango.
Very good.
Sumaho.
What you call me?
Yeah, I called you...
Oh, make 10 photo flashcards.
Nice.
Oh!
Oh.
Wait, how do I... Oh, kyu.
Oh, this one's mysterious.
Okay, hold on.
Reizouko.
Reizouko!
I always... Not always, but sometimes I confuse this word, Reizouko, with the word for candle.
Hahaha.
Sometimes I'll instead say candle, which is... I can't remember right now.
Yes, Rousoku.
Yes, sometimes I confuse the Reizouko.
But I always think of the Re part because it's like the cold, you know?
Rousoku.
Why candle?
It's a bit similar.
Oh.
It's similar to be.
Oh!
Wow, this is a nice camera.
Denshirenji.
I'm gonna turn down the ladies' voice.
It's so loud.
Denshirenji.
I'm...
Oh...
Oh, maybe the voice lines.
That's what we're...
There we go.
Apply.
Danshirenji hype.
What's this thing?
Okay, you put it in the game.
It's important enough.
What is it?
Is it a storage cabinet?
What's in here?
A power box?
I have no idea.
It's important enough to be in the game.
Just a box.
What about this thing?
Oh my gosh, cute!
It even has the kanji for learning.
Manhole.
What are the...
Oh, metal.
Metal.
Do you guys know that bird that they'll be like, Hey, what's this made of?
And he goes, metal.
Or, rock.
Or he goes, shrek.
Because of that bird, I can't not say it as...
Metal.
Apollo!
Yes, yes, yes.
Ana.
Marui.
Round.
Ana.
Hole.
Is that a...
Do it.
Oh, they're so respectful actually.
Sorry.
Is this...
Um...
Baby days?
Could I please know what that is?
Do you want to get isekai'd?
Maybe.
Atelier...
Elise.
Okonomiyaki.
Nice.
Oh, I keep forgetting that we've got this one.
But I kind of want to keep the baby days.
Let's keep the baby days.
Oh my gosh, you could really take a picture of so many things in this game.
Sankaku code!
It's a triangle code!
No way!
The Sankaku code!
Watching your stream at work makes my days so much better.
So have the tip some dude just gave you.
No!
Keep your own tip.
You deserve that.
Tongatta.
Pointy.
Koji.
Construction.
Oku.
To place.
Oh!
Neko Cafe!
Skateboard.
Skateboard!
Gosh, we're so good at Japanese now.
Skateboard.
Sugoi!
Abunai!
Noru.
Whoa!
Skateboard sugoi!
Skateboard abunai!
Skateboard noru.
Who's littering here, huh?
Oh my gosh, it's making a little smiley face though.
Kouhi!
Kouhi nomu.
Kouhi atsui.
Kouhi okiru.
Wake up, coffee.
You're good at Japanese, aren't you?
Arigato gozaimasu.
Kouhi atsui!
But, if you drink it, you're just like, ah!
Atatakai kouhi.
Oh, atatakai.
Or if it's too hot, ah!
Itta!
Oh, I thought that was a ghost for a second.
Where am I going?
I'm, I'm, I'm rising up!
I'm breaking, I'm gonna break the map.
Oh, oh.
I wish I could go inside stores.
Let's see what else we got.
We got a, um, grocery store here.
Oh, sorry, mini-bini.
Let's see what else we got.
Oh!
Sakura.
The sakura.
Under this beautiful night.
First mintsupa ever.
Cause I just got a fat work check.
Ironically, we both learned a bit of Japanese at the same time.
I just took a year-long class and I just finished.
Passed after struggling, but we got a W.
Let's go, nutu!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
And congratulations on passing!
Let's go!
Saku.
What's that one song?
Hana wa hana wa hana wa saku.
Kirei.
Not the tsuki.
Not the tsuki is kirei.
But the hana.
And hanami!
I wanted to do hanami this year.
The sakura bloomed right as I was leaving.
So I didn't get to really do hanami or anything.
Oh my gosh.
The sakura matsuri.
Oh no.
This is a ti- This is a si- A ti- A ti- It's not a titty.
It's a city.
I was gonna say it's a town.
But I also said it was a city.
So I then said it was a titty.
Fuji akishi.
I could read the aki.
Cause that's, you know...
Haru, natsu, aki, fuyu.
We see what we wanna see as well.
I didn't see anything!
I said it.
Oh, what's your name?
Kawakami Nobuo.
Wow.
Oh, hanabi taikai.
Fireworks display.
Oh, this one is written.
Tamura Akiko.
She's like, I'm gonna cry.
I'm gonna punch that guy in the face.
Oh no, their cat is missing.
Minto-chan.
Yes, it's Minto.
Welcome to Mabusha.
Thank you.
They're looking for their cat.
Neko sagashite imasu.
No.
And he has such a cute little hat on.
His name is Kitty.
Oh.
Sei-betsu.
I've never seen osu.
And then nenmei.
San kagetsu.
No, he's so young.
Toki bird.
FPS VTuber.
Facebook.
Chichi.
YouTube.
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you.
He has a little hat on.
Oh, he's so young.
Oh, I thought that was a manatee for a second.
Oh, wait.
Should I take a picture of this?
Keiji-ban.
I'm surprised it doesn't say, like, oshirase or, you know...
Smashful.
Thanks for the five gifted.
A lost manatee.
Atarashii.
New.
Yomu.
To read.
Not yomu.
Not to be mistaken of yomu from the Touhou Project.
Meido.
Jouzu desu ne.
Arigato gozaimasu.
Thank you.
Something choumei.
I can't read.
Sakura.
Oh, sakurai ichoumei.
Meiji chikai.
Sakurai Block 1 Neighborhood Association.
Wow.
The sakurai block.
I guess...
Yeah.
That's where we're at.
Avocado.
Thanks.
Aisukohi.
400 yen.
Not bad.
Today I got to use my yearly exclusive birthday super.
Yippee.
Ganba ananihokominto.
Thank you, Goji.
Wait, are you saying that it's your birthday today?
Are you saying it's your birthday?
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Goji.
What's today?
That is everybody's birthday.
What happened nine months ago?
Jouro.
It's a watering can.
Mizu wo yaru.
To water.
Saimaisuru.
To grow.
Omoi.
Heavy.
Heavy, heavy.
I think this would be good also for like Japanese learners wanting to know English, you know?
Because it's just like, how do I say this in English?
Ranpu.
Oh, wait.
But they don't say the English pronunciation, so maybe it's kind of hard.
But you could be like, akarui means bright.
Or tsukeru means turn on.
Or kesu means turn off.
You know?
Labor day was nine months ago.
All I need is an English voice mode.
Yeah, exactly.
I should make one for English learners as well.
Let's see what we got.
We got kohi for 400 yen.
We got furatowaito.
What is a flat white?
What is that?
Mi?
No.
400 yen.
Coffee latte for 400 yen.
Cocoa for 360 yen.
Kyou no soup.
Today's soup is 520...
What's today's soup?
A type of coffee.
Menu.
Chumonsuru.
Erabu.
Osusume.
Oh my gosh.
I use that all the time.
Osusume wa nandesuka.
Oh, look.
This one has the little picture.
Or the camera.
Oh, and this one has the...
What was it?
Oh, no.
I forgot the name.
Something akishi.
Oh, no.
I forgot.
I'm gonna go read it again.
Oh my gosh.
We almost just died just then.
Were you here before?
Neko.
Surugashikoi.
That cunning little cat.
Kau.
Don't pet.
Kawaii.
Oh, oops.
Let's see what other borders we've got.
Oh.
Oh, this one's so cute.
Wait.
Were you here before?
Why are you giving me that look for?
I like that one too.
Okay.
I was going to read this.
Fujiyaki.
Thanks for the cat, Fake-me.
Oh wait.
If we do this, is it like a tree?
Oh, yeah.
It's a tree.
Oh, this one's also Sakura.
Can you see me?
Or am I a ghost?
For real?
Am I a ghost for real?
I'm a ghost.
Or a vampire, yeah.
If it weren't raining, this would be pretty aesthetic, wouldn't it?
It's not just any yama!
Oh, sorry.
It's not just any.
Can we get there?
No!
The game hates us.
Oh, I guess... Okay, run is a toggle.
I've been like trying to...
Oh, we got the Ginko ATM.
Wow, Fujisan looks so beautiful.
What about this?
Is this like a castle?
Oh, yeah.
Nice.
I wonder what castle this is based off of.
Sightseeing.
Historical.
Nice.
Oh!
Make 25 photo flashcards.
Let's take a picture of our casa.
People are gonna need this.
To get wet.
To hold.
To forget.
Oh my gosh, I forget...
I don't know how many times I've forgotten.
My umbrella in Japan.
It's...
It's two kasa.
Happy basket.
Look at it, a little smiley.
Oh,  They're looking for people.
They're hiring.
Oh,   Murder.
That's Spanish?
No, it's not.
I'm pretty sure I just said Nihongo.
Let's get this little     No, I'm pretty sure I...
Oh wait, I just deleted it.
I'm pretty sure
It's two kasa.
?
La biblioteca.
Yeah.
Like I said,  There's not one here.
Slow down, buddy.
I said  I'm pretty sure that's Japanese.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, are those the train stations that they say in Metal Gear?
You should not just have this out.
That's...
Oh my god.
Let's go steal somebody's identity.
Ryoukou ryoukou niiku...
Motsu I'm stealing this?
I must study this further.
Hotel.
Stop.
Rest.
High.
Safety first.
Safety first, everybody.
You see this everywhere with construction.
Safety first.
Oh my god!
If you get more than 3 pieces of stick, you get 10% off!
10% off 3 or more sticks!
San mai ijou.
Cheap meat!
Wait.
Read the sign.
Uh oh.
I can't read kanji.
Look at this cow.
Why can't I read you?
Oh my god.
I know why.
I know it's the parts of the cow.
But like...
Tomato.
Shoyu.
Egg.
My favorite.
Tamago.
I'll show you.
Waru.
To break.
Yuderu.
To boil.
Marui.
They are round.
Round little eggies.
320 yen for 15?
One star!
You're so expensive!
Every time...
In the past.
So expensive.
Okay!
You guys want a drink?
You guys wanna drink?
What is a Genki-cha?
You could have a super sport!
So you can drink?
You can drink?
No no.
I have the lemon mizu, probably.
Give me some mizu!
Three next to it!
One, two, three!
One more time!
Two, two, three!
Nomi-mono, nomi-mono, nomu, sawayaka, sosogu.
Yeah, I'm not pouring it to anyone except my mouth.
Pour where?
Inside my mouth.
Oh, spaghetti!
Umasagiru!
Too delicious!
DM no spaghetti!
Umasagiru!
Anzen daisan?
Chigau!
Do they have any nikku?
One of the few kanji I actually know.
Nikku!
Let's see.
Oh wait, I wonder what it will say.
Nikku.
Diori o suru.
Kero.
Juicy!
Wow, watashi no juicy na nikku!
Oh, mechakucha oishii!
Oh, umai!
Umai nikku!
Tomare!
I guess we can't take a picture of that.
Oh, it does say, I was gonna say, or we can't read it either, but it does say tomare.
Kowa.
Nani ga kowai no?
Oh, let's make an offering.
And take a picture.
Jinja.
Jinja!
Ojigi suru.
Inoru.
Shukyou.
Oh, yeah, shukyou.
Toro.
Toro!
Prophet daichi.
Yeah!
Prophet daichi!
Akarui.
Takai.
Dekishiteki.
Yeah, I guess it's like very, you know, very Japanese, so I guess you would say historical, right?
Why is it always raining?
Oh my god.
Tori.
Tori!
Dentouteki.
Yeah, but maybe dentouteki would be like more better to say than historical.
Right?
Kourai.
Kuguru.
Onion pan.
Konkari to karamel iro ni yakiageta.
Onion bread baked to a golden caramel color.
Onion pan.
Toten no pan wa subete kokuu.
Oh, no.
Kokusan komugi.
Oh, komugi!
I know that one.
Hyaku pasento shiyoushite imasu.
All of our bread is made from 100% domestic wheat.
Komugi.
Irastoya.
I think this whole game is Irastoya, to be honest.
Look at her.
Mainichi oishii.
Let's take a picture of her.
Tanya.
Tanya!
Shumonsuru.
Herabu.
Yaku.
Look at all this.
Anpan is my favorite.
I love, love, love anpan.
Which is the red bean...
Red bean...
Pan.
Red bean bread.
I learned a lot.
What's your favorite though?
Tax included?
Actually, a lot of places in Japan do tax included.
I feel like most places do.
Or at least they'll show the price and then they'll show the price with tax included.
So you can at least...
You don't have to do the math on your calculator.
You can at least just have the tax and...
It's so awesome.
Zeikomi.
So great.
It's so much easier.
Also, it's so inexpensive.
Shokopan.
Fluffy milk bread.
Yummy.
Three cheese.
Sanchi cheese pan.
French bread.
Melon bread.
Chococorone.
Yummy.
Pita bread.
Oh, it's like a pita bread.
Delicious pita bread is from the...
I can't read.
Just watch...
I'm being loved.
Oh, pita bread.
Why would the bread store be selling pita bread, guys?
Why would the bread store...
That's kinda messed up.
I like pita bread though.
Tofu.
Tough times.
Tough times, nevertheless.
Peter, the horse is here.
Delicious pita bread is love through the ages.
Why would they write that though?
What?
Children eat for free?
Oh my god.
But all... wait, you need to have a... I mean, I'm a child at heart, so like...
Mama Maria.
Everybody go to Mama Maria, apparently.
Oko-sama lunch.
Yes, Oko-sama lunch.
But sometimes they have Otona no Oko-sama lunch.
Where if you want... so it's like the child's... the children's menu, right?
But sometimes they have a children's menu.
So that if you're just like...
I...
Gomi.
I took a picture of you!
So that if you want the stuff on the children's menu, you can have it.
This is the most annoying thing.
Separate?
Ok.
Oh my gosh, one of the most annoying things to like throw away in Japan...
Was my...
Makeup.
Because, ok...
Imagine you get a...
Oh my god!
Eating Mike Tyson's ass!
Thanks for the five, captain!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you.
Imagine you get a waterproof like...
You know, something.
Like a waterproof concealer, right?
And then...
In Japan, you have to like rinse out all your stuff.
And like...
It was so annoying because it's waterproof!
So I'm like...
Trying to get the water inside the little tube.
And then trying to get it to come out.
And it was just so...
It was so...
Annoying.
It was so awful.
Oh my gosh, our picture together.
Well, not together.
Hoki.
Soji suru.
Haku.
Nagai.
Oh, look at this!
What is this?
Fun!
Gumi!
Okashi.
Amai.
Oishi.
Wakeru.
No, I'm not dividing anything.
I'm not dividing...
I'm eating this whole bag myself.
Oh, good morning.
Good morning, world!
Oh, we're back here!
Wait, what's this?
Egao Dori?
What's on the Egao street over here?
Hold on.
We're going down there.
We're gonna go see.
Oh, wait.
We can get Reiko-chan!
Reiko-chan!
Figures!
Atsumeru.
Otaku!!
Otaku!
Shumi.
Watashi no shumi wa...
Idol...
Wait, what is this thing?
What is this thing?
Nuigurumi.
Well, yeah, but what kind of nuigurumi?
Fuwa fuwa.
Takishimeru.
Ageru.
Come here.
I'm gonna give you something.
What is that?
It's a whale?
Perhaps?
Look at her.
My wife.
What if I took a picture of something and it said wife?
It's a business hour.
That's also probably important kanji to know.
Thank you for the 10 gift.
Thank you.
This isn't just in my head.
This isn't just... This is real.
This is not just my chunibyo delusions.
This is real.
I like this.
Cute!
The decora!
Erindoll fan exchange meeting.
She must be so popular.
Popular idol.
I love that there's a clip art for chunigirl.
Irastoya is amazing.
They have so many awesome...
Promenition of love.
They have so many different illustrations.
You would be surprised.
Taisen kakudo.
You got the...
You got the fighting game floor.
You got the ongaku game floor.
Oto- I mean, sorry.
Oto-ge.
Oto-ge floor.
The ongaku game.
Oto-ge.
Race game.
Prize game.
Crane game.
What's down this way?
Look how cute.
Did someone just leave their purse and their food?
I'll take that.
Tame-mono.
Yummy, yummy.
Taberu.
Oishii.
Karai.
Game game.
What's this one?
Look at how fancy you can make these.
Look.
Look at this.
Look at the bouquet and everything.
Nomimono.
Charlie!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Can we go?
Can we?
Banana!
Orubako!
Yes, danboru.
I know that because of...
Because of...
The girl with the... Yotsuba!
Just a box.
Sumeru.
Hakobu.
Akeru.
Yakitori!
Just a box.
Can I go upstairs?
No!
Why would you deny me?
What's the point?
Oh.
Egaodori.
Smile Street.
Man.
I was so excited.
Take a picture of the door to darkness?
No?
Okay.
Wow.
I guess it's a pretty small map, isn't it?
Otakuma.
Get it?
Because it's otaku and kuma.
Kuma is bear.
And then otaku.
Otaku.
Kuma.
Did someone mention the door to darkness?
That's the bear.
Hey, a maid cafe?
Yes!
It's based off of Maid Dreamin'.
Actually, the sign is pretty close.
And the logo.
Maid Dreamin'.
Maid Melody.
Let's play in the land of dreams.
Oh.
Demon King's life.
Access denied, though.
They banned me.
I've been banned from the maid cafe.
I've been banned.
Wait.
Guitar girls?
Nijukan Hatsu.
Oh, wait.
Nijukan Hatsubaichu.
Hatsubaichu.
It's another one you hear all the time.
On sale now!
Have you guys ever heard of guitar girls?
It's probably like...
Lifetime ban!
No.
They wouldn't ever.
I mean, they kicked me out by my butt and said, If we ever see you again here, we're calling the cops!
But I don't think they mean that for a lifetime.
I don't think they mean that for that long.
Probably until like next week, you know?
They kicked me to the curb right on my poor, poor bottom.
And they said, You better not step another foot inside this establishment, or we're calling the cops!
But I don't think they meant that for life.
If they meant it for life, they should have said, In our whole life!
But also, I'm dead.
So...
That's kind of discriminatory to me.
I don't...
My afterlife never ends.
They're just being tsune?
Yeah, I hope so.
Fusen!
Fukuramashu.
Waru.
Pan!
Oh no!
Why is it making this face?
Pan!
Eien da!
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Wait, can we go down here?
Fujiaki Dendetsu.
Fujiaki Electric Railway.
Sakurai.
Sakurai Station.
Oh my gosh, I wanna go see Shizen ni Modoru.
Is he gonna...
Wait a second.
Why is the chef...
Why is the chef around all these edible animals?
Also, what a movie to release.
Okay, is this a romance?
It's being released on Valentine's Day.
Wait.
What is he intending to do with them?
Return to nature?
Like, return them to nature?
Or...
Whoa!
Can I get...
Oh.
Looks like that plane had some panties on.
Wait.
Where did it go?
Huh?
Ghost plane?
Where did it go?
There's another cat.
Cat.
This is such a beautiful scenery.
Oh wow, I actually got something.
Leight.
Light.
High.
Legible.
Okay, I want a picture of him with the leaf falling in the background.
Really artsy, you know?
How was Paz today?
Oh my god.
She is such a troublemaker.
She is such a little troublemaker.
She is so...
Wait, no.
I wanted it behind it.
Hold on.
Let's try another one.
Oh!
No!
I was too late.
She... Okay, so I have from my time in Japan when I went to high school.
I have a thousand paper cranes that my classmates created for me.
And I've kept it all this time.
And guess what has holes in it now because she can't stop biting it.
She's like...
All the time.
And then there's also a box that I have.
Filled with letters that were sent to me.
And she keeps trying to knock it over.
There's too many letters that I don't know what to do with them yet.
I might have to get like a really really really big scrapbook or something.
But I don't know what to do with it yet.
And she keeps trying to knock over the box.
She is such a menace.
And so she'll go from the box to the cranes.
Back to the box to the cranes.
And then she'll try and chew on every cord that I have.
Which, you know, by my computer.
I have quite a few.
So she's just such a troublemaker.
She's such a...
Why did your classmates make a thousand cranes for you?
Oh, because I was leaving.
I was going home and so they were like...
Minto-chan, we had so much fun with you here.
We'll miss you so much.
Yeah, I was leaving.
So sad.
Not because you died.
Why would they make that for me?
Because I died.
Where are the leaves?
It looks like it's on his head!
Old.
History.
When you...
Basically the thousand cranes is like you make a wish.
So...
Murphy, thanks.
Crazy.
It's like people like you or something.
That'd be...
Why?
Huh?
No.
Why?
What is the top one so we can tell Matara?
Furui.
I think...
I feel like...
Rekishiteki would be like a sick insult.
You know?
Instead of like...
Instead of calling someone just old, you call them historical.
You're just like...
Damn, girl.
You're not just old.
Like, you are historical.
Like...
Whoa.
Rekishiteki.
It's like ancient.
But like...
It's like a sophisticated insult.
Knowing her though, she'd take it as a compliment.
Can I take a picture of the rock?
Iwa?
Iwa!
Wait, what's the difference between rock and rock?
What's the difference between Iwa and ishi?
Are ishi smaller?
Ooki.
Omori.
Katai.
What about this?
Shokubutsu.
Ueru.
Shizen.
Ha.
Oh!
This is Akihabara.
Ha.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
I gotta tell it a joke.
I gotta say a joke.
Your mom.
Ha.
It's here.
I should be able to take a picture of everything.
Oh, the cat!
No, this is a different cat.
Litter!
Oh, just nomimono.
Why don't you call it Mizu?
You're right, your mom is haha.
See?
It's a pretty sophisticated joke, is it not?
Oh, hats, coats, accessories.
I love this.
Everything is a borrowed word except Boshi.
Which...
Is that...
Is that a Chinese-taken word, I wonder?
If anybody knows.
But it's so funny, everything else is a borrowed word.
Boshi the Rock.
Wait, why can't I read it?
No, why can't I read it?
I can't read!
Double row!
Double!
Single!
No, no, no.
No, no.
I can't read it.
toisletto peipa.
Toilet paper!
They're a taco!
Thank you for the purl opera choppy you!
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Arigato.
So one thing I had to learn.
Or rather, you learn kind of quickly.
Is...
Is when you say...
So you'd say like, you know, when you're at a restaurant, you get something on your mouth or whatever, you use a napkin.
But in Japanese, napkin has a totally different meaning.
Don't go to a restaurant... well, you could.
You could go to a restaurant and ask for a napkin.
But um...
But uh...
You might um...
What does it mean though?
It means...
It means a sanitary pad.
Things that...
You know...
When you're on your period.
So if you go to a restaurant and say, Hey, can I get a pad with my meal?
People might be like...
Uh oh, we have a freaky...
Unless you're at...
Wait...
Did...
Did that...
Did that podcast episode go up about...
The jail?
I think it did though, right?
Oh wait, no, it wasn't the podcast.
It was with Giri.
The collab with Giri.
Where...
I went to a prison themed restaurant.
And um...
And what restaurant would that possibly be normal?
Exactly what I'm saying!
There was...
There was a...
A jail themed restaurant.
And they would serve like um...
They would serve like a strawberry jam type stuff on a sanitary napkin.
It wasn't menstruation themed cafe.
They just had...
I think it was just that one thing that was.
Which...
I would hope there's nothing more.
It's soft.
It sits.
It's round.
A clinic.
But this by itself is a medicine.
And this...
The...
This one.
The kyouku.
The kyouku part.
The kyouku part is um...
Kind of means like a...
Type of...
How do you say?
Like a building?
Not a build...
Like a...
How would you say?
If the okyaku-sama asks for a napkin, the okyaku-sama shall have a napkin.
That's the Japanese service I expect.
Oh can we go...
No!
This is an important kanji right here.
This.
This is an important kanji.
Tabet.
Taberu is to eat, right?
Tabe.
Houdai.
Sometimes you will say nomi in front of this.
Nomi.
Houdai.
Tabe.
All you can eat, baby!
All you can eat.
3,200 yen.
Wow, that's not so bad for all you can eat.
All you can eat, baby.
Yeah, and then nomi houdai.
All you can drink.
This is an important Japanese.
I think it's an important Japanese.
How much is that in America?
Nowadays, maybe like 25 dollars.
Maybe like 25 dollars.
Oh sushi.
Hayashi sushi.
Hayashi sushi-ten.
Yummi.
More like 20?
Wait, is it that bad?
More like 20 bucks a current.
See, I thought I was being generous with 25.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I should order some yen.
I've been trying to like order yen.
I typically have been using my card as much as I can while in Japan.
Stonks.
Stonks, stonks, stonks.
Will it go back?
I don't know.
Have you done Snake Eater?
I think that would be a good one.
Yen and Cat are around the same, so I guess that's 30 bucks.
No, I think that's too much.
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna look it up.
Yen...
Wait, oh!
Wait, is this from today?
Oh my gosh, I have an AmiAmi payment request.
Oh, okay, it's not so expensive.
That's for a free rent thing that I got.
Okay, um...
I just noticed it though.
Oh my gosh, okay.
USD to Yen.
Okay, Yen...
3,200.
It's 20 dollars!
Oh my gosh, you guys were right.
Pyrobug, thank you for the 10.
Thank you for the 10 memberships.
Thank you!
Also, Shabu Shabu.
Shabu Shabu.
I want to eat it.
It's delicious.
I love Shabu Shabu.
Hmm...
Have I gotten a picture of a car yet?
Car!
Drive!
Fast!
Slow!
Can I go down here?
Oh wait, there's another entrance for Sakurai Station.
Sakurai Station.
But what line is it?
Hmm...
I wonder.
Shabu Shabu is the best.
Oh no!
People are leaving their stuff everywhere!
Bag!
What is that?
I don't know why it's in...
I've always wondered why it's in...
Katakana.
Is it a borrowed word?
If so, where is it borrowed from?
Ireru!
Dasu!
Hakobu!
Kaban-chan.
There is a kanji for it.
Kaban.
Why in Katakana though?
Are they leaving their suitcase here?
Can I take a picture of the graffiti?
Oh my god, I can!
Raccoon City.
Rakugaki.
Rakugaki!
The first one!
Iho!
Illegal!
Kaku!
Colorful!
Oh my god.
Not the...
Illegal!
Oh wait, here!
Shashingo!
Shashingo, you're doing illegal activities.
Oops.
Rakugaki.
You're doing illegal activities.
What have we missed?
I think there was an area to the left down here that we didn't go to.
And of course, Fuji-san.
Yeah, over here.
Bathroom.
Excuse me.
Pedestrian walking.
A wonder fill.
My favorite!
My favorite, my favorite!
My favorite flowers!
Hana.
These are ajisai!
They're my favorite!
I dreamed of love.
I love ajisai.
Kirei.
Mizu wo yaru.
Saku.
Hydrangea.
Can I crouch in this game?
Oh nice.
So I can get like a really aesthetic nice photo of the hydrangea.
Hana.
Wait, no, no.
There we go.
That's better.
Hana.
What are you doing here?
Neko.
What are you doing there little cat?
This is how...
This is how my cat looks at me.
Toilets.
Can I not take a picture of the toilets?
Oh.
Kinyan!
Smoking is prohibited.
No smoking.
This says toilets.
In case you couldn't figure it out.
Wait.
Why is it like this?
What is this?
Oh okay.
So this is for like the...
You know, the bigger ones.
And the ones for like families and stuff.
This is the...
Ladies room but...
Why is there also a man sign right there?
Hmm.
Why do the doors have windows?
I don't think there...
I think this is only the one that's one person.
But you can't see inside.
Because it has the lock thing down here.
That.
And it's occupied.
I gotta pee.
Please let me in.
Anybody.
Let me in.
Please.
Oh my god.
I'm not gonna make it.
There's so many.
There's so many magazines.
Oh there's our guitar girls.
What is this one?
Oh!
Before you go home...
Give me a kiss.
...
Gochokun.
What is it?
The ways in which you talk to me.
Satoru.
Make me wish that I was gone.
Wait, no, I said his name two times in a row.
Wait.
Manga.
They're both named Satoru!
They are?
Really?
Oh.
Can I read the titles?
Rosebend.
Manga.
Paperbound.
Paperboundo.
Honya.
Where's the grab your magazines?
Is it you?
No.
This is a fashion magazine.
I don't care.
Where's the grab your?
Where's the baboom and the babang?
Where is it?
One, one, jump.
Oh, it's like a game.
Woof, woof, jump.
Suma hold it down.
No, don't.
They keep the steamy stuff inside.
I want...
I once stayed at a...
At a hotel that was across the street from a...
I guess a publishing company, but they published like a ton of...
Like...
Um...
Uh...
The...
It was like...
Not Shonen Jump.
But one of the magazines that has like the steamier...
The steamier...
The more...
Ooh la la...
Mangas and stuff like that.
And so they just had them out on display...
I wonder if I have a picture.
Hold on, I'm gonna look.
Because...
I was so like...
It was so funny to see it every time I would...
Let's see.
When did I go?
When did I stay?
Maybe this trip.
Hmm...
No...
Wait.
Maybe it was this trip.
No...
I'm looking at my phone right now.
If you couldn't tell.
Does it say Nenmanga?
I guess maybe technically.
But it was like...
So sexy.
It was so sexy.
And like they also...
Like you know how...
Um...
Like...
They'll have the...
The grab your models on the front and everything.
And I would like go and get food.
And then every time I would pass this...
This...
Like...
Sign of...
Sexy girls.
It was kind of awesome.
Hmm...
No...
Oh wait.
Was it this one?
No...
When did I stay?
When did I stay there?
I can't remember at all.
Hmm...
I'm staying at too many hotels all the time.
This is...
Is it this one?
Is it this?
No...
Ah!
If I can find it later, I'll show you guys.
It was a really nice hotel though.
It was a very nice hotel and it wasn't very expensive.
Um...
And it was a good location.
So...
Um...
I'd recommend it to you guys if I could remember.
I never gonna remember when I stayed there.
I have no idea.
Hmm...
My memory is going.
Wait.
Is it this one?
It's gonna bother me now.
I'm so sorry.
I know I'm just like looking for it.
But it's really gonna bother me if I don't...
If I don't look...
If I don't look at least a little bit.
If I don't...
Wait.
I'm under camera, right?
Yeah.
Under camera.
It was definitely with this camera.
But it wasn't here.
Not there.
Not that.
Who knows?
You can find it, Mint.
I can't.
Oh.
I can't find it.
I wanna play Guitar Star.
I feel like this is such a good game actually to...
Like learn so much.
Yeah.
We got our menu.
What's your favorite kind of ramen?
I think for me, my favorite is shoyu ramen.
Which is...
Like the soy sauce.
Tonkatsu.
Wow.
Lots of people saying tonkatsu.
Really?
Classic tonkatsu.
Tonkatsu.
See you.
Wow.
Sorry.
So many people push tonkatsu.
Wow.
Karaage.
Miso.
You so what?
You so hum.
I think I've only ever had Mr. Noodle.
What's a Mr. Noodle?
Boo.
You guys love it.
Thank you.
Boo.
You guys are too kind.
Black garlic tonkatsu.
Okay.
I like anything with garlic in it too.
Oh my gosh.
When they're just like toppings, I'm like, give me that garlic.
Put as much garlic as you want.
Moyashi is what?
Moyashi is...
Oh.
Moyashi is the beans.
Not the beans.
I keep wanting to say soy sauce.
I mean, I think it's a stream bean, but it's not that.
It's bean sprouts.
Thank you.
Bean sprouts.
I don't like a Moyashi.
I always get no Moyashi.
I don't like Moyashi.
Don't like it.
Yeah.
It's not my favorite.
But they add crunch.
I don't like it though.
I don't like bean sprouts.
Eww.
Yeah.
See?
Every good person does that.
I also... like Japan loves cabbage.
And I don't mind cooked cabbage, but like, raw cabbage is so...
They'll just have a pile of raw cabbage and I'm like, the taste is so strong, it's so bitter.
I'm not a big fan.
Mmm, cabbage.
I like it though if it's... cooked.
Cooked cabbage is awesome.
I prefer raw to cooked cabbage?
Why?
Can we read this?
No.
There it is.
Tonkotsu ramen.
There you guys go.
Pork broth ramen.
700 yen for a full stomach.
For 700 yen, you will be full.
Full stomach for 700 yen.
Tonkotsu ramen.
Yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy.
Curry.
Wait, I cannot even...
Who puts white text on top of yellow?
I can't even read it.
I can't even...
What is a curry retort?
Curry and curry.
If you're a student, you can't read it.
Oh, I can't read it.
Oh my gosh, it's so hard to read.
I can't even read it.
Oh, no pets.
Pet kinshi.
Bojoken douhan ka.
Oh my gosh.
Kinen.
Shashinkin.
Oh, sorry.
Satsuki kinshi.
Helmet chakuyo no de.
I can't read anymore.
Helmet chakuyo de.
Yuten kiji.
So you can't wear your helmet inside?
It's kind of a weird request, right?
Wow.
Chusen de.
Oh, chusen is like an evil word, right?
It's a lottery.
Chusen de.
Hachiman mei sama muryo onigiri.
Do a lot of people still smoke in Japan?
Yeah, they do.
I think so.
They do.
What's the difference between kinen and kinshi?
Kinen is specifically for smoking.
And kinshi is just like...
For... like...
Not allowing you to do something else.
So it can be like...
Tachiri kinshi.
Do not enter.
Daily reminder, love you men.
Inyamae, thank you!
Oh, thank you.
Yeah, no problem.
So for that, petto kinshi is...
No pets.
Tabacco.
Osake.
Oden!
Ginko ATM.
What does this say?
Bhan kamera.
Sado chu.
CCTV camera.
Bhan kamera.
Wow.
Wait, can I take a picture of this?
No.
They don't want me to take a picture of the sign.
What else have I gotten?
Oh!
Where's the moeru?
Oh, moyaseru.
Moyaseru gomin.
No, I like it when they say moeru.
Because it's kind of like...
Moe.
Sometimes like...
I've seen places...
It's funny.
I think it's specifically like...
I've seen them in Akihabara.
But like they'll kind of make a joke about like...
Moe.
You know, moe being like...
Moe moe kyun.
That kind of moe.
But also moeru means like...
To burn, right?
Moeru gomin is like...
Burnable garbage.
So...
Moeru.
Moeru gomin.
What does moeru gomin mean?
I don't know.
Moeru.
No moeru.
Oh.
Gomi bako.
Kitanaai.
Ippai.
Recycle suru.
May I put your beans and your cans and your pet bottles?
Oh my gosh, it's your bowl, you guys!
Food bowl.
Ippai.
Aku.
Kitanaai.
Okay.
Eat up!
There's no food.
Sad.
We'll do it in black and white because it's depressing that there's none.
Kaido no Aki no...
It's like... Okay, so flavor and then remember.
So it's like...
So is it saying like, remember the flavor of Hokkaido...
Hokkaido...
Fall?
I love a kabocha so much.
Oh.
Autumn taste?
Wait.
Mikaku!
Hokkaido no Aki no Mikaku.
Kabocha croquette.
Inume!
Thank you!
Mikaku!
Bet she would feed us nothing but raw cabbage.
What?
No, I care about you guys more than that.
Or, if we go someplace...
I would give you my raw cabbage that I don't want to eat.
Rice!
Welcome to Menboship.
Thank you!
I love a kabocha pumpkin.
So good.
Kabocha croquette.
I love croquette too.
Do we go over here?
Udon.
Teuchi udon.
Shinosuke.
Handmade noodles.
Wow.
Wait, are these like the samples?
Are they gonna say... Oh, they do say tabemono.
But this isn't tabemono.
So, actually, one thing that's really fun...
I don't know if you... I did it through school.
So I don't know...
I don't know how easy it would be for foreigners to book an appointment.
But you know how, like, in Japanese restaurants, they'll have the sample foods that, like...
Like, exactly like this.
They sit outside and show you what kind of stuff that they...
The ultra-realistic plastic models.
Exactly!
I went to... I went to a factory.
I don't know if you call it a factory.
But I went to the place that makes them.
They actually do have a gift store in the front too.
That you can... I think anybody can go to...
Open to the public.
And buy some kits that you can make your own.
But also...
I think it would be really fun if you ever go to Japan and you're wanting something to do that's kind of unique.
They do have, like, workshops where you can create your own.
And then they show you the process.
I think we made, like, tempura.
And then you get to take it home too.
So...
It's really cool!
It's really fun!
And they have...
They... I wonder if...
Let me see if I can find it.
Let's see.
Sample...
Japan food sample...
Workshop?
I don't even know what to search.
Food sample making workshop in Tokyo.
Oh my gosh!
Wait, it just took...
It was so easy to search.
I don't know if this is the exact place that I did it at, but...
Is that some place in Ikebukuro?
I don't remember where I went to.
Maybe this is it.
Hmm.
But yeah.
I guess you can book it as a...
And then they also have the gift shop.
So if you're just like...
Oh, we made this thing, but I want to make this at home.
Like, I bought a melon soda one.
So...
Yeah.
I recommend that kind of experience.
It's so fun!
It's my...
Osusume.
Remember?
We said Osusume?
What is this?
There's no menu there, so...
Icicle here.
These...
These places always have this specific ice cream cone.
Gosh.
Just leaving their sumaho outside.
How do I get coins?
Oh, sticker.
Sticker.
Soft cream.
What flavor do you like?
Haru.
Hagashu.
Chisai.
Try a different mode.
Oh, these are all our pictures!
Numbers!
Cute!
Oh, wow!
Here's all your hiragana and katakana.
Hiragana dakuten.
Katakana dakuten.
Wow!
Numbers!
Oh!
Wow!
Oh my gosh!
There's even greetings and stuff?
Ohayou gozaimasu.
Yaho!
Irashaimase!
Irashaimase.
Moshi moshi.
Oh!
It's a man.
Ohayou gozaimasu.
What's the next page?
Expressions.
Domo arigato gozaimasu.
Oh my gosh.
Makoto ni arigato gozaimasu.
Gomen nasai.
Otsukaresama.
Yeah.
This is pretty detailed.
It even has like...
Look at this!
Wow!
They're telling you all about it.
Like, Sunday has the kanji for sun slash day.
Saturday is the kanji for earth.
Friday is the kanji for gold money, baby!
Getuyobi.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, it doesn't...
Okay, it doesn't tell you the...
The meaning.
Days...
Two?
Kyou ashita asatte kino ototoi.
Heijitsu.
Shuu.
Shumatsu.
That's important.
Cause shumatsu is awesome, baby.
Complicated kanji.
How many pages are there?
Watashi.
Anata.
Omae!
Omae.
Very informal way of saying you and sounds very rude.
Oh!
Nanda kore wa?
Kore wa nan desu ka?
Sore wa yuzu desu.
Sore wa nan desu ka?
Kore wa wasabi desu.
Oh, and it teaches you like the difference between kore sore are.
Ah.
Natto wa dore desu ka?
Are desu.
Anata?
Kimi?
Wasabi.
Kore wa wasabi desu.
This is great for people... beginners, right?
Genki de wa arimasu.
Sounds pretty genki to me.
Play it up a little bit more samu.
Hana-chan wa doko desu ka?
Koko desu.
Moka wa doko desu ka?
Soko desu.
Oh, sorry.
I just heard a dog bark.
Did I imagine that?
Did a dog...
Mitsu.
Inu.
Fuwa fuwa.
Naderu.
Kao.
Oh my gosh.
Shibako.
It's like the...
Atashi ni esa wo ataenai de kudasai.
Please, do not feed me.
Oh, whoa, he's even got money.
Whoa, he's got a lot of money.
Okane.
Okane, baby.
Harau.
Okane mochi.
Bimbou.
No.
Oh, wow.
Otsuri wa okaeshi dekimashen no de...
Oshiharai kudasai.
They can't do change, so you pay the...
Oh, it says right.
Pay the exact amount.
You got their gummies.
It's just...
It's a...
It's a pun on tobacco.
It's even like the same...
Same kind of font that they use in Japan all the time.
Thanks for the coin.
Okanega nai.
Murphy, thanks for the coin.
Doggo can't do math.
No, doggo...
Wait, who...
Ok.
I'm sorry.
Who spent 1,500 yen?
How much would that be now?
130 dollars?
110 dollars?
Well, who spent over 100 dollars on snacks?
I would too though.
He's a good boy.
He's such a good boy.
He's such a good boy, they do.
They do.
Sorry.
What was I doing though?
I was doing something and then I got distracted.
Was I still looking at the samples?
No, I closed out of that.
I don't remember what I was doing.
Sunny is atashi, so isn't the dog a girl?
Oh, you're probably right!
Oh, someone's... Oh yes, that's right!
We were going through here!
I was like...
Thank you!
Where is Yuki-chan?
Where is Yuki -chan?
Over there!
I want Yuki to become a Vtuber, she's so cute!
Oh, we have some vocabulary.
Making sentences...
Yuki-chan, this is Sam.
Nice to meet you, I'm Sam.
I'm a photographer.
Nice to meet you.
She's a photographer!
Yes, amazing!
She's so cute!
Wait, I think I need to turn the... Oh my god.
Sorry, the voices are so low.
Let's turn it up just a little bit.
There we go.
Wait, is that a voice changer?
She's so cute!
I am Yuki!
Yuki...
You are the photographer.
Yeah, I'm Mito.
And I'm 5 years old.
Nice to meet you!
Yeah, it's amazing!
What's scary?
Why is she scary?
Yuki is scary, but Mito is scary!
Wow!
The photographer is cool, isn't he?
I am Yuki.
I am 5 years old.
Oh, no.
I am stealing her identity.
I am Mint.
I am 5 years old.
Nice to meet you.
Yuki, this is Sam.
I am Sam.
I am a photographer.
Nice to meet you.
Wow!
The photographer is cool, isn't he?
I am Yuki.
I am 5 years old.
Nice to meet you.
I am a robot.
I am 5 years old.
I am Yuki.
Mint isn't just a child at heart anymore?
Makinga All right.
can't miss this scene.
Nice to meet you.
I am Tom.
I am a photographer.
Please allow me to be your photographer.
All right, all right.
I'm done.
Oh, no!
There's some more!
Everyone.
I have prepared dinner.
Sam, do you like curry rice?
Yes, I like it.
Wow, he sounded...
Oh my gosh, I don't think he was saying that about the curry.
That sounded more like...
Yes, I like it.
Like...
That sounded like a confession to me, right?
Yes, I like it.
I think he likes Hana.
It's my favorite food.
Then, itadakimasu.
Itadakimasu.
It's delicious.
Yes, it's delicious.
Gochisousamadeshita.
Yes, I like it.
Oh my god, I'm gonna be listening to this just like...
I feel a little bit lonely.
Samusan, do you...
What do you think about me?
Yes, I like you.
Oh my god, Samusan.
It's too early, we just met today.
Samusan, konichiwa, konichiwa.
Isho ni nanika shimasenka?
He's asking her on a date.
Kyou wa hima desu.
Watashi mo desu.
Atarashii hon wo kaitai desu.
Oh.
Chikaku ni honyasan wa arimasu ka?
Un.
Koko kara jygo fun kurai desu.
Wow, there's so...
We're on page 24.
Let's buy a book.
Are you gonna buy this book?
Un, kau.
Oh, oh.
Rival, rival, rival.
Wait, oh no, that's the tei-in-san.
The tei-in-san.
We can't see the rival?
There he is.
There he is, there he is.
What, is my head too big or something?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, this is actually so helpful.
Wow.
Oh, and then it stops there.
But that's a lot.
That's a lot of stuff that they...
That they include in this.
I'm actually so impressed.
Bye bye ritsu.
Bye bye.
Wow, beautiful.
Oh wait.
There we go.
Cho.
Capture a butterfly.
Oh, there's an achievement for it.
Wait, what's this?
Oh.
Tegami.
Kaku.
Okuru.
Shiteki.
Gotta answer the point card question with daijoubu desu.
So you skip the next question.
Wait.
If they say do you have a point card, you can't say daijoubu desu.
Just say...
Are you saying like, oh they're gonna ask you if you wanna make one?
Right?
Daijoubu desu.
Why are you spying on other people's mail?
Because I'm a snoop.
I gotta get all these pictures.
I have all these pictures to take.
Though I answered daijoubu desu to probably 99% of them.
I answered daijoubu desu to probably 99% of them.
Oh my god.
Square watermelon.
Suika.
Kudamono.
Chokusuru.
Dekai.
Look how expensive it is though.
Oh my gosh.
It's so dang expensive.
Carrots.
You guys, I ate a whole bag of carrots.
Recently.
Ninjin.
I ate all of them in one day.
I love carrots.
Yasai.
Kenkouteki.
I ate them all because they're kenkouteki.
They're healthy.
Can you see in the dark now?
Just carrots?
Some with hummus.
But mostly just by themselves.
Saibaisuru.
Hoya da daikon.
Daikon.
That's a nice radish.
Harukiru.
Mikan.
I love a mikan too.
Kudamono amai.
Marui.
I can also eat a whole bag of these in one day.
But then my stomach hurts.
So I don't do it.
Not often.
Only sometimes.
What about the choco chips?
Okashi.
I'll get this one too.
Arubaito osagashite...
osagashi desu ka?
Arubaito.
Osagashi.
This is me.
I'm gonna go work at the grocery store.
Are you looking for a part-time job?
A whole bag?
Yeah, I can eat a whole bag.
Bonsho chuu desu.
Mabashi Burando.
Horse.
What is this one?
Something something chui.
Go...
Go kata?
Goho?
Chui?
I don't know.
Koho...
Koho janai no.
Koho chui.
Oh my god.
I'm nothing jozu.
Nothing jozu at all.
Nothing jozu about it.
Wait, actually...
Can I get a picture of the ajisai in the...
in the rain?
Oh my gosh...
Why did it have to turn dark?
Wait...
Oh, I want a picture of the train too.
Guess we'll wait for it to come back.
Sorry everybody.
I gotta get my shot.
I want the moon in it also.
Pachinko!
Sora.
No, no, no, no.
Delete, delete.
It doesn't pause.
Densha.
What a terrible photo.
What the...
Oh!
Sora.
Densha.
Yeah, we got the pachinko in the background.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Is that lighting?
I don't know what that was, to be honest.
Noru.
Oriru.
Hayai.
Pachinko.
Kanban.
Dang.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hikouki, hikouki.
Hikouki, hikou.
Hikouki.
Tooi.
Toubu.
Ryokou ni iku.
Remember the rule of thirds.
Didn't it highlight the sky?
Oh, I've already taken a picture of the sky.
You can see it.
It's hard to tell.
I can't show my mouse on it.
But it says Sora.
Uh-oh.
We're causing a pile up here.
Sorry, everybody.
Go ahead.
I'm not sorry.
Right?
We're not sorry at all.
We're ready to cause chaos.
In this little town.
Can we go downstairs?
No.
Oh, yes.
This is where the...
Okosama no...
The, um...
Their meal is free for the kids.
Okosama menu.
Do you guys feel really Nihongo jozu now?
Do you guys feel like you've learned so much?
I think I might actually call it here.
I know it's like super duper...
super duper short stream.
But my throat is hurting...
quite a bit.
So...
Sure do.
Wait, hold on.
Let's get the perfect photo of Fujisan first.
Excuse me!
You are hindering my photo.
Let it be a little...
bit lighter.
See, it's kind of...
twilight.
Fujisan.
Slightly more jozu.
Nihongo peko peko desu.
Anzen daichi.
Anzen daisan!
Hello?
Is it gonna...
become daytime?
Yama.
Oh yeah, see?
Before it was raining.
Fujiyama dekaiyama.
Dekaiyama!
Dai san.
Shanshin daichi.
Satsuei daichi.
Anzen daisan.
Dai nii wa...
What is dai nii?
Dai nii wa moe.
Sugoi dekai Fujisan.
Oh!
Yama.
Yeah, baby!
We got the ultimate photo.
Yama.
No, let me see it.
I'm gonna heart the Yama.
Hmm hmm.
Maruku nai?
Hmm hmm hmm hmm hmm.
Wow.
It's so beautiful.
Utsukushi keshiki.
Arigato!
This was a comfy stream game.
Honestly, it looks more useful than the Green Owl app for learning Nihongo.
Have a good rest.
Thank you!
Aka Fuji!
Look at that little cat.
So cute.
Yeah, I'm actually so shocked at how...
I feel like how effective this is.
Oh my gosh!
Do you see it?
Even the kanji is in the...
Look how cool that is!
Wow, what a beautiful picture.
Oh, I missed the shot.
I missed the shot.
I want another car to...
Wait, what am I highlighting?
Super!
I'd love to see this game grow.
Me too!
Me too, honestly.
I think it'd be great for like, especially kind of the kanji you see in everyday Japan.
I think.
Super duper helpful.
Come on car.
Go!
Turn, turn, turn, turn!
Turn down the streetcar.
Someone turn down the street.
Go home.
Did someone say super?
Super?
No!
Wrong super!
Wrong word.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Kuruma.
There.
A very like...
Japanese-like picture.
So Japanese.
Japanese.
They need an N2 version of the game.
Yeah.
It's a...
Yeah, just like having...
Everything...
I don't know even what N2 would be like though.
It would be so intensive, right?
It would be like every individual thing, right?
Hmm...
But it looks like almost that they want to add more maps.
You know, because...
I mean, they have this area...
Oh wait, can you get the fish?
Fish!
Swim.
In the water.
It's kind of a bad picture, but it's okay.
Pretty much hence the invisible wall.
Fish!
Vocab is pretty good, Ayamo.
I think so too!
I think it's really, really good.
Yeah.
Oh my god, wait!
So cute!
Wait, is this the cat from over here?
No!
There's just cats everywhere.
Now focus on the cat.
Wait, I don't...
I wish I could lift it up a little bit more.
But it goes out of...
There we go.
Oh no!
I clicked the wrong thing.
Okay, once more Sakura fall and then we'll be...
Nyanco.
Nyanchan.
What's the cat doing?
He's...
He's contemplating his life choices.
Don't do it, cat!
I pressed left click but it didn't work.
Yeah, he's Hanami right now.
Hanami.
No!
Wait.
Oh, it's not letting me take a picture because I'm not focused on something.
Oh, that's a terrible picture.
That's a terrible picture.
Kawa.
Can I get this one too?
Is this a bridge actually?
I can't tell.
I guess not.
I was hoping it would let me take a picture of the bridge but...
Hmm.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm really sorry for the super duper short stream today.
But I just really wanted something kind of chill that we could explore around a little bit and learn some Nihongo and hang out for just a bit.
And hopefully you learned something.
Hopefully.
Thanks for the chill stream.
Of course, of course.
If you're wanting to learn Japanese, I actually recommend this so much because look at this.
You can go to a sign and you can be like, this looks like something that you would see totally normally.
And so if you're just like, uh, uh, uh, uh, like, uh, what does this mean?
You know?
It's, uh, super duper helpful.
Hmm.
It was fun and educational.
Yes.
Educational.
I want to play this game so bad and I'm N3.
Do it!
Anyway, I think I mean, there were even some words that I was like, oh.
And then for me, kanji is so bad that it helps me a lot.
I learned today that mint is kawaii.
That word wasn't in the game.
Thanks for the chill stream.
Of course, of course, of course.
Arigato, Minto-sensei.
I'm not the sensei.
Don't worry.
This game is sensei.
Wow, thanks for the fine gift and membership.
Thank you.
Oh!
We almost died.
We almost died again.
Whoa!
I want to watch that.
Spankenheim!
Thanks for the 10.
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you so much.
April 26, baby.
I do hope that they, there is like DLC for this game, but it's only for filters.
So hopefully they add more maps and I don't think I'll stream it again, obviously, because, you know, it's just, it seems more like a good way to study on your own and have an interactive way to study if you're more of that kind of person who like learns better by like being like,
oh!
Kutsu!
Kutsu.
Like that, you know, then it could be really good.
Hakku.
Hashiru.
Usubu.
Arigatou gozaimasu.
This was fun.
Thank you, guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
With more advanced Japanese words on certain maps.
I think it would be good.
Still have to eat that, by the way.
Oh!
Look at the time!
Okay, everybody!
Otsu mitou!
Thank you.
Itterasai, everybody!
Thank you for watching!
That's all for today!
Dodododo Dodododo Hotaru no Hikari Wado no yuuki Otsu mitou!
Otsu, Otsu mitou!
The moon is beautiful, isn't it?
Bye bye!
Bye bye bye bye bye bye Bye bye!
Have a good night!
Bye bye!